[Musique]
il
benoît gruel bonjour emmanuel vénaux
bonjour merci d'être tous les deux sur
le plateau de tv soixante dix huit pour
ce vip qui vous est consacré vous êtes
ici car c'est une partie d'une compagnie
qui s'appelle l'éternel et et qui est en
résidence à versailles qui va bientôt
proposer un spectacle
le capitaine fracasse qui sera jouée
samedi 1er juin à 20h30 dimanche de juin
à 17h au grand dit curie à versailles
voilà maintenant on va pouvoir faire
connaissance avec vous on est dit
l'essentiel
j'ai tout dit au revoir non alors dites
moi vous par exemple benoît vous êtes
venu au théâtre commence et c'est quoi
un peu votre parcours en quelques mots
alors moi je viens de jantes maritime
j'ai ouïe et tendre
j'ai découvert le théâtre dans mon
village par une compagnie amateur et je
suis resté pendant dix ans il est parti
avec eux je suis parti avec eux moi j'ai
sillonné la france à droite à gauche
ouais j'ai vu monter un festival j'ai
fait plein de trucs avec eux j'étais
enfant à l'époque vous enlevez ils m'ont
enlevé noms de la musique de votre plein
gré ou de mon plein gré c'est génial
puis voilà après j'ai fait des écoles et
dans mes écoles j'ai rencontré des
membres de l'éternel était petit top qui
étaient déjà constitués en fait vous
vous existez depuis 2010 je crois depuis
2010 selon les échos et vous alors
racontez moi et maniaque bino moi je
viens de carpentras et vers où est basée
la compagnie est de la france mais
finalement c'est tout se retrouver plus
ou moins à paris jeunes comédiens
connectés soit encore en école sur juste
sortie d'école et ils étaient 1 à
guetter c'est d'abord une histoire
d'amitié c'est vrai c'est parce qu on
était amis qu'on a eu envie de faire du
théâtre ensemble d'accra c'est moi je
viens j'ai créé ma compagnie adam on est
une troupe on vit vraiment dans un idéal
d'un esprit trop pour une douzaine de
comédiens maintenant voilà depuis 2006
oui c'est ça on a une dizaine mécano
fracassé la première fois qu'on est
quasiment au complet on est onze
comédiens au plateau qui fracasse
capitaine fracasse été fracassées sens
que vous allez jouer là dont quelques
bientôt
dans le cadre du mois molière j'ai pas
encore prononcé le mot mois molière mais
qu'elles ont donnée démarrer le mois
molière oui on est très fiers que même
ceux proposés là sur le doubs jean louis
lemay ce d'ailleurs à vous a repéré à
avignon paraît c'est ça le maire de
chance ce soit un grand fan de théâtre à
cannes au festival d'avignon et ont
présenté il ya deux ans et fourberies de
scapin de molière donc il nous a pas
raté est vraiment à la sortie du
spectacle quasiment il nous a proposé
dix après mois la rentrée foot vous
propose quelque chose
ouais donc tout de suite après avignon
rentrée 2010 est on a été associé va
vers ça l'est d'accord c'est venu comme
ça
oui parce que les deux spectacles que
vous avez joué jusqu'à présent c'est le
cercle de craie donc l'année dernière à
versailles escape un pan du coup quand
même au prix que vous avez repris aussi
voilà donc là c'est une création le but
ne tracasse meilleur de vous donnez moi
par exemple je ne sais pas l'idée un peu
de votre troupe ses choix que de
l'interaction avec le public vous êtes
non pas parce que ça glisse et défend un
c'est quoi votre théâtre populaire déjà
voilà donc donc ça va bien avec le mois
molière exactement exactement c'est la
même idée là depuis c'est ce qu'on a
proposé à versailles c'est la première
fois dans il sera compagnie que un des
comédiens de la troupe prend en charge
d'un projet oui à la rade
on n'a pas dit qui faisait quoi voilà
donc benoît vous nous transmettez en
scène ce spectacle
oui voilà vous jouez vous jouez pas je
joue pas de banjo je vais pas
m'enflammer habituellement je suis
comédien
voilà c'est ça habituellement je suis
metteur en scène et vers le héros se
trouve inversé souvent je suis comédien
dans l'eau fracasse vous êtes sinon
directeur artistique de la troupe au
final barils à tout dire mais oui
doit-on donc vous regarde populaire
depuis plus d'un an et demi
benoît a eu cette idée du capitaine
fracasse un projet que qui portait aussi
avec faustine guillard et manu élevé
livre c'est l'adaptation semble dire au
monde que c'est parce que oui c'est un
roman théophile gautier que vous avez
adapté en pièce de théâtre voilà
d'accord et c'est pour quels publics ou
là c'est pour tout le monde pour tout le
monde
l'idée c'est que c'est un spectacle
qu'on a créé par tout le monde pour tout
le monde c'est c'est à dire que c'est un
spectacle qu'on a créé avec les
versailles et pour les versaillais
c'est un spectacle qui va se jouer pour
l'instant mais il ya de grandes chances
que au mois molière ou vraiment un
spectacle aux offres
il est on a voulu le créé en
collaboration avec les habitants
c'est ça que je voulais c'est à dire
qu'il y avait hier quoi qu'il ya des
associations locales qui nous ont aidés
à créer ce spectacle il y en a même
plusieurs qui joue avec nous sur scène
viable dire qu'on est 46e mais pas que
les douze comédiens sur scène dans
plusieurs associations davies a
il ya un quatuor de cors classique qui
s'appelle le quatuor massif
ils y allaient l'homme du roi qui est
une association de deux comédiens
escrimeurs artistique en quart et il ya
une chorale qui s'appelle le coeur
montansier et donc tout ce petit monde
c'est vrai que ça fait quarante
personnes sur scène fait d'accord vous
répétez tous ensemble et je sais pas non
on a eu du mal à se retrouver
et là ça va se jouer dans les derniers
mois les derniers jours avant le premier
d'accord et être en résidence et va ça
ça veut dire quoi concrètement
vous avez un lieu pour répéter oui c'est
à dire que ont déjà on se sent accueilli
par une municipalité ça c'est important
ce sont désirés venise rarement cas il
est venu vous savez on est venu nous
chercher et on nous a dit bienvenue
devenez vous implanter à partir des
glaces et là on réfléchit d'ailleurs à
déplacer son siège social de la
compagnie et à versailles témoin on s'y
sent bien
donc en effet il ya un appartement qui
est mis à notre disposition qui nous
servent surtout de du lieu de réunion
d'entrepôts de costumes d'accessoires
etc
ça fait vraiment un point de chute pour
le conali c'est important et c'est
important pour se retrouver et puis il
ya évidemment cette association avec le
mois molière où on sait que on sera les
bienvenus jacques à chaque édition en
fonction de ce que vous avez un cahier
des charges vous êtes sensé
je ne sais pas oui on est censé
travailler sur le territoire c'est à
dire que notre appartement rue
saint-nicolas et associés notamment
l'école de la source puis après on s'est
rapproché des maisons de quartier etc
on essaye de travailler enigmz est le
capitaine fracasse
un projet qui a été créée main dans la
main avec la mairie de versailles s'est
jamais choisi ensemble
non c'est vous qui avez apporté proposé
ça on a proposé l'idée mais ils nous ont
proposé certaines associations on a ça a
été ça fait un an et demi qu'on
travaille avec eux vraiment est-ce que
déjà dans votre idée c'était d'être plus
nombreux que la compagnie elle-même est
d'associer au lycée ça va en fait on a
voulu dépasser leurs attentes ils ont
dit venez à versailles vous implantez
travailler avec des écoles de notre
exemple et en fait on a dit ok on vous
proposait encore plus travaillant avec
des associations menton un grand
spectacle et c'est vrai que c'est pourri
et avec versailles parce que on a fait
ce spectacle pour pour le mois molière
tous les conciles visite privée ne sera
pas jouer ailleurs
c'est vraiment une création pour ex
maison pour ne concourra pas délocaliser
de cette annonce apparaît démesuré mais
justement c'est pour ça aussi que mr
veut se servir sur les ouvertures succès
un seul être un grand grand spectacle
est ce que c'est une première cette
façon de travailler pour nous il est
toujours
le mois molière et déjà eu des gens là
on sait pas avec autant de personnes
autant d'associations différentes je
sais pas du tout même à croire que non
mais bon on ne sait pas c'est juste
énorme là vous êtes vraiment sur scène
40 vraiment d'accord il va y avoir une
captation
on espère oui on dise oui il va y avoir
une captation oui est-ce que si on peut
plus vous voir après c'est ça mais c'est
ça qui fait la magie aussi c'est
vraiment vous travaillez depuis un an et
demi on en fait on a répété plusieurs
semaines pour jouer deux fois ça c'est
magnifique
et est ce qui est des enfants qui jouent
avec vous non finalement non non j'ai
longtemps essayé mais non il y aura pas
d'enfant style alors heureusement québec
d'accord quelques dates fracasse on peut
dire en deux mots quelle est l'histoire
de ce roman adapté en pièce ce que tout
le monde le capitaine fracasse et un nom
qu'on connaît mais après l'histoire
c'est l'histoire d'une troupe de théâtre
itinérante qui sillonnera votre enfance
ça fait penser à notre enfant ça fait
penser à l'éternel dit eh oui à mon
enfance raconte et à l'air oui
complètement
c'est ça bien sûr en fait c'est la
troupe dans la troupe s'est évidemment
ça parle aussi de nous quoi c'est pour
ça qu'on doit on aime cette histoire
donc en fait c'est un homme qui ne fait
pas partie d'une troupe qui les voit
jouer sur sa place du village c'est pas
ça non je vois dit moi la troupe donc
trébuche la la roue de la charrette de
la troupe se casse à côté d'un château
il rentre dans le château et là il ya le
noble nex jarrett d'accord désargenté
qui va finalement rejoindre la troupe et
partir avec eux oui je les suis aussi et
devient comédien il devient comédien on
en connaît un autre vous en photo
oui bon très bien et vos projets alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer après ce
alors la 6e manche et l on travaille sur
mon travail sur deux spectacles et
créations saison prochaine il y aura une
adaptation d'un check off 1 ivanoff
qu'on a retraduit pour l'occasion pour
la troupe son concept à midi ça donne
c'est comme ça du rugby ex truths
complètement avec un ami l'ukrainien
mais qui est il bien évidemment en russe
joue dedans aussi
voilà donc il ya 120 traduit ce kof on
regarde traduit pour vraiment me
traduire traduit ici retraduire s'il ya
des versions qui existe
qui nous semblait très poussiéreuse donc
on a envie on a été bouleversé par la
pièce qui parle aussi du passage de la
crise de la trentaine qui commence à
mener comment ça nous pendre au nez
complètement dans la troupe
donc on voulait parler de ça se servir
de ces pièces finalement et envers le
traduite pour gars vraiment à découper
sur mesure le texte pour les comédiens
c'est là que vraiment on a traduit en
sachant qu'ils avaient joué un rôle
donc on a vraiment fait ça pour sur
mesure pour la droite d'accord donc le
titre de la pièce et ivanov milanov
ivanov de tchekhov et on monte en
parallèle un jeune public
on a beaucoup joué des jeunes publics
depuis la création de la compagnie
montage chaîne publique
on monte un spectacle destiné aux
enfants oui bon chrétien
on montre le jeune public oui c'est vrai
qu'on dit comme ça donc on crée
cendrillon cendrillon aussi dans une
nouvelle crypte eurent donc assez plutôt
vraiment vous et vous et pour les
enfants
donc tout ça ce sera notamment au
festival d'avignon en juillet 2020 on
pourrait retrouver sai on espère au
molière avant juillet enjoint de mais
voilà c'est ça que j'avais envie
d'entendre non alors dans un an après
avoir été séduit par le capitaine
fracasse le samedi 1er il dimanche de
juin on va rester sur notre faim et on
va être très patient en attendant
l'année prochaine pour retrouver donc
ils vont nous encourager en fit la noce
de tchekhov pour les grands oui mais
plutôt exactement tous les sons brigitte
une cendrillon font rien pour tout le
monde voilà qui va jouer cendrillon
l'organe turris benoît joue dans le
cendrier homélie suis pas cendrillon non
d'accord et alors quel regard vous allez
donner sur cette cendrillon cette
histoire c'est ça on a commandé donner
envie parce qu'on connaît tous
l'histoire un jour un chemin vers
cendrillon un peu commun que tchekhov
d'être on est un peu dans cette mouvance
est là est un peu comme avec
l'adaptation de caden fracasse ailleurs
on a voulu se réapproprier l'histoire
pour vraiment faire quelque chose de
propre cerf que vous comptez assez
révoltant dans les clichés qu'il impose
notamment entre les rapports hommes
femmes
la pauvre jeune fille qui a besoin du
prince pour réussir sa vie nous mène
mais plutôt contre ça à wemmel oui vous
pouvez ou même les apports serveurs à
auxerre c'est très intéressant par
contre ça c'est des clichés face à vous
de les plus forts parce que la rivalité
fraternelle ça on est resté là dessus
elle se trouve que c'est quelque chose
qui correspond toujours à notre époque
alors que me cliché du trouvaient le
prince pour réussir sa vie c'est quelque
chose qu'on compte
plus dire en tout cas cette idée donc on
a voulu réécrire cendrillon on a
beaucoup c'est l'histoire de cendrillon
évidemment en écriture collective avec
les comédiens ceux ci la première fois
qu'on fait ça j'écrivais un comédien et
moi dans le il y aura que cinq comédiens
pour l'instant donc à nous si ce n'est
qu'à on avait écrit l'histoire pour
essayer de bouleverser un petit peu les
codes gens cliquent sur des endroits
différents et pour présenter une
nouvelle histoire qui pour elle ne l'est
plus à notre époque en tout cas une
vraie cendrillon moderne qui donne envie
aux petites filles parce qu'elle sait
faire exactement génial de mons qu'on
vous devez écouter merci d'être venus a
très vite avec beaucoup d'impatience sur
les planches des grandes écuries à
versailles pour démarrer le mois molière
en beauté en fanfare avec le capitaine
fracasse benoît emmanuel un grand merci
et à très vite merci merci à vous un
phare
[Musique]